mais thierry amouroux du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
bonjour thierry amouroux vous êtes porte
parole de ce syndicat
un petit mot sur bruno le maire à votre
égard par rapport au personnel soignant
il a dit je salue les personnels
soignants exceptionnelle de dévouement
de courage et de professionnalisme
comment est ce que vous prenez
cette remarque est ce que c'est un appel
justement pour pour renforcer le secteur
hospitalier au moment où je cite selon
olivier ferrand la situation s'est
dégradée dans plusieurs métropoles ces
derniers jours il y en avait un beau
numéro de joueur de flûte
celui qui a parlé dévouement et l'autre
qui a indiqué que nous avions le soutien
de la nation alors les mots sont beaux
mais la réalité est tout autre c'est à
dire que lors de la première vague les
soignants nous avons servi de chair à
canon parce que nous n'avions pas de
masque pas de sur blues pas de gang 31
mille d'entre nous ont été victimes du
coc vide faute de matériel du fait de
l'attitude irresponsable du gouvernement
qui avait supprimé les stocks
stratégiques de de masques et bien
figurez vous que ce gouvernement qui
nous parle du soutien de la nation a
décidé que tous ces soignants qui se
sont donnés à fond qui ont mis en danger
leurs proches leurs parents et bien
n'aurait pas la reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle sauf les
soignants décédés ou ceux qui ont été
hospitalisés sous assistance
respiratoire
on peut difficilement faire plus
signable c'est dire allez-y
ben maintenant temple il s'était pas de
foot vous avez qu à mieux vous protéger
même si on vous a pas fourni le matériel
mais nous on veut pas en entendre parler
et bien semer tri a eu pour conséquence
que les soignants et bien ils sont bons
vous avez 7500 postes affirmé vacances
juin nous sommes à trente quatre mille
postes d'infirmiers vacants aujourd'hui
avec de plus en plus de jeunes qui s'en
vont qui s'en vont pour partir à
l'étranger qui sont bons pour partir en
libéral parce que nous avons on nous
parle de salta envoyé sur le front
mais notre problème c'est que nos
généraux nous tire dans le dos alors
voilà on est assez démotivés on est
fatigué on est fatigué parce qu'on a
beaucoup donné
on a beaucoup donné pendant le pic
qu'ovide physiquement psychologiquement
et alors que deuxième pour la cabine est
en train d'arriver
qu'est ce que vous redoutez mais juste
avant ce j'aimerais rappeler les
principales annonces notamment à les
vilains qui passe en alerte maximale ce
sera samedi il s'agit de lille grenoble
lyon saint-etienne et dijon et clermont
passe en alerte renforcée samedi matin
toulouse et montpellier pourront passer
lundi en alerte en alerte maximale vous
nous parlez de démotivation thierry
amouroux
alors que certaines villes on le voit
pas son alerte maximale même s'il ya des
améliorations dans d'autres comme du
côté de aix marseille 2 2 bordeaux ou
encore de nice alors qu'il ya des villes
qui passe en alerte maximale dans quel
état d'esprit est ce que le corps
médical et infirmier sont nous sommes
fatigués nous sommes fatigués parce que
la première vague a été épuisant mais ça
veut dire que deuxième catastrophe à
venir c'est ça moi je vous me posez une
question sur l'état d'esprit des troupes
je vous le je vous le dis moi je n'en
sais rien
je décris la la situation que nous
vivons avec un gouvernement qui continue
à fermer des lits d'hôpitaux qui
continuent à fermer des lits de
réanimation comme les quatorze lits de
réanimation du chu de strasbourg
voilà donc on est fatigué parce que la
première vague est épuisante
pendant tout l'été nous avons essayé de
récupérer le maximum de patients notre
nom qu'ovide qui souffraient de
pathologies chroniques et qui n'ont pas
pu être traités pendant les trois mois
de la période qu'ovide nous avons essayé
d'en prendre le plus possible tant que
le temps que nous pouvions donc nous
sommes fatigués les wii 2 et voir le
gouvernement décidé de continuer à
fermer les délits d' accélérer les
choses même puisqu'un décret est sorti
le 3 septembre pour licencier et les
fonctionnaires hospitaliers en cas de
restructuration d'hôpitaux ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent passer à une étape
supérieure de fermetures de lits de
services et d'hôpitaux ce qu'a annoncé
d'ailleurs monsieur macron il ya deux
jours en disant on va restructurer
l'hôpital vous êtes mal organisés et
interpellé un quand il était en
déplacement à il ya deux jours
du côté de l'hôpital la fondation
rothschild par départ des soignants qui
demande plus de moyens plus de
professionnels ce à quoi le président a
répondu avec il fallait une meilleure
organisation qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
et bien que les jeunes ont répondu avec
leurs pieds ils s'en vont on est passé
de 7500 postes vacants à 34 milles et le
mouvement n'est pas forcément terminée
parce que les pour ceux qui restent
l'ennemi contre son gré n'a servi à rien
a au contraire ça a été un facteur
d'accélération
parce que on nous a annoncé par exemple
sur l'aspect salarial
nous qui sommes payées moins 20% sous le
salaire
mais européen que pendant le pico vie de
monsieur vers ans s'était engagé à
verser 300 euros aux soignants à partir
de juillet le finalement au moment du
ségur
il a changé d'avis en nous disant bon
allez vous auriez 90 euro cette année
puis à 93 euros de plus l'année
prochaine et on sait que ça va durer
pendant dix ans mais j'aurais pas
d'autres améliorations
donc on sait qu'on va continuer tous
deux saouls pays et à être exploités
donc les jeunes se dit mais pourquoi je
vais travailler en sous-effectif en
étant sous payés avec des conditions de
travail déplorables
alors que je peux aller travailler en
suisse et au luxembourg pour installer
un infirmier qui sera lu toutes les
coutures à mon gros ça veut dire que
pour cette fameuse deuxième vague dont
tout le monde parle ça veut dire que
l'hôpital n'est donc pas prêt alors que
quand on entend le ministre de la santé
olivier véran on semble prêt home et
monsieur vers en est pas à une
affirmation vous savez vous l'avez
entendu pendant la première vague sur
les 4 milliard de masques sur l'état
reste voilà bon ça continue eux ils sont
dans la communication
nous nous sommes dans la vraie vie et
dans la vraie vie bien nous tire dans le
dos en fait une manipulation de
soignants qui est prévue le 15 octobre
est ce que vous appeler à manifester
bien sûr nous sommes un certain nombre
de syndicats a appelé une mobilisation
le 15 octobre pour les soignants qui
sont encore à l'hôpital encore envie de
se battre pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses
face à un gouvernement qui ferme des
lits supprime des postes
voilà mais le plus inquiétant ce sont
ces jeunes professionnels qui qui s'en
vont alors
le ministre de l'économie j'ai fait
maintenant alors maintenant il doit
sortir son carnet de chèques c'est
maintenant qui doit rendre l'hôpital est
attractif
vous savez on ne manque pas d'un firmi
en france on en forme 26 mille par an
mais vous avez 180 mille infirmières qui
refusent de travailler aujourd'hui parce
qu'elles ne veulent pas se faire
exploiter dans des conditions de travail
souvent mal traitante pour pour les
patients et donc il faut réenchanter
l'hôpital
re motiver donner envie à ses 180 me
infirmière de revenir prendre prendre un
poste ap il ya plus de ressources pour
le secteur hospitalier
alors que le directeur général de
l'agencé régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france a parlé tout à l'heure
de mobiliser toutes les ressources
justement parce qu'il prévoit une marée
très forte de malades du coronavirus
qu'est ce qui va se passer ces
prochaines semaines à l'hôpital et la
grosse difficulté par rapport à la
première vague c'est que la première
vague était centrée sur deux régions
ile-de-france éléments test et on a pu
faire appel à des soignants d'autres
régions qui sont revenus renforcer nos
équipes de ces deux régions et on a pu
lui envoyer des patients dans d'autres
régions pas toucher là cette fois ci la
deuxième frappe toutes les régions en
même temps donc y aura pas de renforts
inter régions et aujourd'hui nous avons
moins de lits et moins de soignants
qu'en janvier mars contre temps si tu
passes par hyères a prédit que 100%
des lits de réanimation seront occupées
d'ici à la fin du mois ça vous inspire
quoi
aujourd'hui nous avons toujours ça me
lit de réanimation
j'ai les mêmes qu'au moment de la
première vague parce que non dit de plus
en selon le gouvernement s'il devait y
avoir un nouveau petit pli de mick
s'agit et c'est très bien et dans la
pensée magique au moment de la première
vague on a fait 2000 lits de plus que
les 5000 en prenant les respirateurs des
blocs opératoires et des salles de
réveil qui ont été fermées pour qu'ils
aient plus d'activités programmées
donc on ne sait plus occupé des patients
chroniques des interventions non vitale
non urgentes
mais ça fait 2000 de plus et là
aujourd'hui nous sommes toujours qu'à
cinq lits dont 10 % ne sont pas ouverts
faute de personnel infirmier
merci thierry amouroux d'avoir répondu à
nos questions